Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir sitzen hier vor dem Salon, möchten euch ein Jahresende-Angebot einen klugen Gedanken geben. Mit dem Buch sind wir heute sehr gut bedient, glaube ich. Spektakulär. Oder?
Es hilft, wenn man Statistiken lesen kann.
Ja, bilanzieren ist nicht verkehrt. Und auch der ein oder andere Gedanke, der sich bei mir so verfestigt hat, aus See- und Sprechgewohnheit, ist vielleicht noch mal zu überprüfen.
Oh, ja, also man wird wirklich geschult in einem Denken, dass man viel zu wenig sonst leistet oder auch geleistet bekommt. Das ist einfach unglaublich, wenn wir einen Ökonomen haben, also Branko Milanovic, der eigentlich Experte für globale Einkommensungleichheit ist, aber von dort ausgehend dann sich fragt, wie verändert sich die Welt geopolitisch? Er hat die richtigen Zahlen dann zur Hand und hat jetzt nicht solche, wie in Deutschland beliebten Spiele, ja, was will der Putin da und was möchte Trump dort machen? Er schaut einfach auf die ganz großen Zahlen und die großen Veränderungen der letzten Jahrzehnte. Es ist so unglaublich, was dann plötzlich zutage tritt und dieses ganze psychologische Wühlen in ist der Xi vielleicht eher so oder so, spielt gar keine Rolle mehr.
Aber was ist dann deine Antwort?
Ja, das ist aber genau die Haltung. Wer BEP-Wachstum verspricht, kann so schlimm nicht sein. Und wir geben, wir kennen ja zum Beispiel auch von Hayek diese Aussagen, wie ist das, wenn eine Diktatur da ist? Dann würde der auch sagen, ja, bevor sozialistische Ideen sich breit machen, hat er ja auch so formuliert, ist dann eine faschistische Diktatur vorzuziehen. Nicht auf Dauer gestellt, aber das kann zunächst einmal doch weiterhelfen, dass man wieder ein bisschen auf Trab kommt.
Ja, das Problem ist halt, in dem AfD-Programm, das ja Steingart nicht liest, weil er einfach nur von Weidel fasziniert ist, steht drin, Rentenniveau 70 Prozent. Also es ist ganz unvereinbar wiederum mit dem, was er da labert. Also man wüsste gar nicht, also wenn jetzt eröffnet der AfD Tür und Tor und dann ein Jahr später, wie jetzt Rente 70 Prozent, was? Also ich wollte eigentlich 47, nicht 70. Steingart meint es wirklich, der ist ganz überzeugt.
Mit den Konzernschefs, mit denen du redest, du bist wahrscheinlich einer der best vernetzten in der deutschen Wirtschaft, sagen das viele das gleiche, was du mir jetzt gerade gesagt hast.
Ja, und zwar die sagen alle dasselbe. Da ist ganz viel braune Soße. Damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben. Damit darf ein demokratischer Politiker nicht koalieren. Nicht koalieren und dann und dann kommt der Punkt 4. Aber wir müssen ein Gespräch trotzdem beginnen darüber, wie Deutschland reformiert werden kann.
Ja, das heißt ja einfach als Arbeitsaufgabe für die AfD. Bitte haltet die Identitären klein oder vielleicht könnten wir da ein Verbot hinbekommen. Lasst den Höcke draußen. Der kann höchstens dann noch auf Landesebene den Zampano machen. Aber bitte auf Bundesebene übernimmt das neoliberale Programm von Steingart vollends. Und bei Fragen der Migration haben wir sowieso keine Differenzen mehr. Insofern ist das ja eine ausgemachte Sache. Das Einzige, was man eben nicht möchte, ist, dass man jetzt zu sehr jetzt vielleicht noch die Waffen-SS oder so glorifiziert. Das wäre wirklich ein bisschen unangenehm. Auch gerade im Ausland sieht das bisschen hässlich aus. Aber sonst können wir eigentlich alles machen.
Milanovic beschreibt es ganz wunderbar. Jelzin, besoffen, aus dem Amt, wie auch immer. Und ganz Russland droht einfach diesen Oligarchen zum Opfer zu fallen. Also kommt so ein Typ auf die Idee und sagt, komm wir nehmen aber diesen Putin. So ein kleiner, zarter Typ, der ist so schmächtig, der äußert sich nie. Keine Gefahr.
Der hat keine Ideologie.
Genau. Und dann glaubt man, man könnte mit ihm gemeinsame Sachen machen gegen die Oligarchen. Ein Jahr später ist Vladimir Putin der Zar der Oligarchen. Und 25 Jahre später ist er es immer noch. Also diese ganze Idee, die er hier hat mit, ja, ich möchte den Sozialstaat abräumen und die SPD macht ja irgendwie nicht mit, die linken und grünen sind eh verloren und vergessen, lass uns doch mit der AfD machen. Aber diese ganze braune Soße, das ist ja nicht so wichtig. Wir wollen ja nur kurz den Sozialstaat abräumen. Danach geben die uns das Land bestimmt zurück.
Dann machen wir das.
So, und dann ist irgendwann 2055 und wir müssen wieder Bücher schreiben über, dass man mit dem Führer war, auch beim zweiten Mal keine gute Idee. Ja, das droht hier einfach. Kostenverkleinerung, ja. Wir müssen jetzt die Kruste verkleinern, letzter Clip.
Und wenn wir uns auf dieses Ziel, wir vergrößern jetzt den produktiven Kern, verständigen, dann leiten sich viele Maßnahmen genau daraus ab. Weil dann sortiere ich die Welt, vergrößert es die Kruste oder den Kern. Rentenreform im Bundestag? Eine eklatante Kostenvergrößerung. Weg damit. Tariftreuegesetz, wo jetzt jede kleine Firma Tariflöhne zahlen muss, also Lohnerhöhung. Schadet ihnen auf den Weltmärkten. Weg damit. Also verstehst du, ich brauche ein sehr klares Raster. Das versucht dieses Buch jedem Menschen zu geben. Dieses klare Navigationssystem.
Ja, dieses Buch sagt den Menschen, du sollst verarmen, damit es der Klasse, die ich repräsentiere, besser geht.
Du bist Größte, du musst weg.
Ja. Und wenn du im Kern bist, dann hast du dich gefälligst noch viel mehr anzustrengen, weil ich gerne für meine Klasse mehr rausholen will.
Ja, das ist wirklich eklig einfach, das ist ganz, man will es einfach abschütteln.
Ja, deswegen, ich will das hier mal als Ansatz machen, ich will also nichts mehr hören auf irgendwelchen Podiumsdiskussionen. Man wird ja doch viel eingeladen. Ja, was tun wir gegen die Gefahr von rechts? Und damit wird immer die AfD gemeint und Fake News im Internet. Dann stellt bitte die Frage, was tun wir gegen den Springer Verlag? Da können wir gerne mal darüber diskutieren. Was tun wir gegen öffentlich-rechtliche Talkshows, die mit solchen Leuten besetzt sind? Ich will nur noch über diese Fragen diskutieren. Ich habe keine Lust, mich daran aufzuhalten, ob man die Publizistik in Schnellroda verbieten sollte oder nicht. Die spielt keine Rolle. Hier wird die große Politik gemacht. Diese Leute drehen am Großen Rat.
So ist es. Termine. Ich war bei Lanz. Mit mir war dort die Chef-Volkswirtin oder was auch immer der Welt.
Bei der Welt bekommt jeder so einen Chef-Titel.
Ja, das sind alle immer Chefs. Also sie ist irgendwie die Wirtschaftschefin, keine Ahnung. Frau Siems und zwei Professoren und Institutsverantwortliche. Einmal aus dem IFO-Institut, einmal vom Bevölkerungsforschungsinstitut hier, von BIP. Und freut euch bitte auf zwei Argumentationen. Zum einen, alle feiern immer so Hartz-IV-Reformen ab und so. Und ich will das auch an niemandem madig reden. Nur ich denke mir, vor 20 Jahren waren die Armen dran. Jetzt brauchen wir wieder eine Sozialstaatsreform. Jetzt soll es um die Reichen gehen. Zweites Argument. Und da bin ich auch erst drauf gestoßen, als ich mich auf die Sendung vorbereitete, weil der Herr Peichel vom IFO-Institut selber da war als Autor. Typischerweise sitzt man ja im Fernsehen immer mit irgendwelchen anderen Politikern oder so oder Leute, die mal so ein Kommentar schreiben. Aber Leute, die so echte Forschung machen, das ist schon was Besonderes. Und der Herr Peichel hat letztes Jahr einen Text mitverantwortet, der davon handelt, wie sich die Lohnentwicklung von 1983 bis heute entwickelt hat. Das ist also genau die Erwerbsbiografiephase der Boomer, die heute in Rente gehen, die Deutschland zur drittgrößten Volkswirtschaft der Welt gemacht haben. Die haben also richtig reingebuttert. Sie haben während ihrer Lebensarbeitszeit das BIP verdoppelt. Wirtschaftswachstum 100 Prozent. Und es war natürlich die Frage, die ich an den Text stellte, wie haben sich denn die Löhne in der Zeit entwickelt? Auch verdoppelt? Und der Herr Peichel schreibt von Dekaden der Stagnation und Reallohnverlust. Und da liegt natürlich die Frage auf der Hand, wieso ist denn dieses produktive Wachstum niemals in die Rentenkasse angekommen? Warum reden wir hier über zu wenig Junge, zu viele Ältere und so weiter und so fort? Hat es vielleicht, wie Moes Höfken schon schreibt, gar nichts mit Jung und Alt, sondern mit Reich und Arm zu tun? Und nachdem dann die Frau Siems ewig lange ausführt und hier und da und so, habe ich dann die Rückfrage an sie, wo denn das Leben in ihren Ausführungen vorkommt. Denn ich habe ja auch daran teilgenommen und ich habe das eigentlich, glaube ich, es war keine Vater Morgane, als es hieß, da ist irgendwie eine Lehman-Bank-Pleite gegangen und jetzt ist da irgendwie ein Angriffskrieg und jetzt sind da irgendwie Inflationen 10 Prozent. Ach ja, eine Corona-Krise haben wir auch noch. Findet einfach gar nicht statt. Sie guckt einfach so in die Bücher und sagt, also für mich ist das alles, ist alles gleich anything to me. Wie so ein Host da aus Westworld und so. Na ja, also es ist die letzte Sendung von Lands des Jahres. Ich glaube, die kommt am Donnerstag.
Prima. Und noch einen Termin im Januar hattest du?
Am 9. Januar in Erlangen abends mit Obie Florian Janik. Gespräche über die Kinderwüste. Für ganz Ausgewählte ein, jetzt fällt mir der richtige Name nicht ein, aber es ist superwitzig. Denn ich habe ja gesagt, das ist ja direkt neben Nürnberg. Ich würde gerne mal die historischen Städten, als das mit dem Führer noch funktioniert hat und so sehen. Und bei mir hat sich Thorsten gemeldet. Und es ist superwitzig, wenn man fragt, also er ist Rundgangsleiter, möchte ich damit sagen. Die Pointe ist, er nennt sich Rundgangsleiter, weil natürlich, also Guide könnte man auch noch sagen, aber alles, was Führer im Namen hat, geht natürlich nicht. Also haben wir den Rundgangsleiter Thorsten gefunden. Thomas aus dem Fernsehpodcast und ich werden also einen Rundgang mit Thorsten machen. Und wir hätten vielleicht noch so ein oder zwei, aber bitte nicht einfach nur flapsige E-Mails schreiben jetzt, sondern wirklich so richtig kleine Bewerbungen, warum ihr mit uns da fünf, sechs Stunden mit verbringen wollt.
An Stefan, an deinen Adresse.
An mail.stephanschulz.com, dann nehme ich das gerne in Begutachtung. Und dann können wir uns da einen schönen Tag machen.
Wir werden also jetzt in den Salon rübergehen und sprechen dann über Branko Milanovic, The Great Global Transformation über den Nationalmarkt-Liberalismus in einer multipolaren Welt. So der Untertitel. Es ist ein sensationelles Buch. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie wir da gleich darüber diskutieren werden. Ich hatte eigentlich angekündigt, dass ich das Buch von Thomas Wagner bespreche. Ich habe mich nicht gegen das Buch entschieden. Das kommt nämlich dann im nächsten Salon. Aber wir müssen uns auf einen Text viel intensiver konzentrieren. Ich habe da so viel zu sagen, dass es einfach schade wäre, wenn ich das Sachbuch dann nur kurz verhandle. Denn ich habe 150 Seiten der EKD gelesen, der Evangelischen Kirche Deutschlands. Die haben sich zu Krieg und Frieden geäußert. Und es ist empörend. Es ist skandalös, dieses Dokument. Ich bin ja schon aus der Kirche ausgetreten. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wenn Leute das jetzt hier hören werden und die in der Kirche sind, wie sie sich dazu verhalten. Ich will nur kurz sagen, man kann ganz leicht aus der Kirche austreten. Es ist ganz einfach. Man braucht nur schnell zur Stadtverwaltung, braucht wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal einen Termin. Und das ist ein Gespräch von fünf Minuten. Also man muss sich auch nicht rechtfertigen, sondern einfach nur was unterschreiben. Es ist nicht zu fassen, wie der christliche Pazifismus hier nicht nur abgeräumt wird, sondern wie hier eine Kirche für Musterung, für Wehrpflicht plädiert, für atomare Aufrüstung und sogar noch das Fliehen vor Krieg unter Bedingungen stellt. Also ich bin so empört darüber und glaube ich muss da ganz lange drüber reden, habe hier fünf Seiten Exzerpt. Das wird also das große Thema, das zweite für mich im Salon sein. Außerdem noch einen Roman aus Japan über einen Tokyo Sympathy Tower, so heißt der Titel, in dem die Kriminellen leben sollen und die sollen dann aber paradiesisch leben, denn die Sprachpolitik will es, dass über alles nur noch positiv gesprochen wird. Es ist aber jetzt nicht einfach so ein antipolitical correctness Roman, sondern ein bisschen differenzierter, interessanter. Fünf Prozent des Romans wurden mit Chechie Petit geschrieben, hat die Autorin auch gesagt. Außerdem beschäftigen wir uns nochmal mit dem Kulturpass und ziehen da Bilanz. Und es wird von mir auch noch einen Musiktipp geben, nämlich es gibt eine neue Winterreise-Einspielung. Ich habe ja schon mal die Winterreise hier von André Schuhn empfohlen. Nun, Johannes Martin Krenzler, grandios.
Okay.
Aladin El-Mafaalani hat ein Buch geschrieben. Wichtiges Thema Vertrauen und Misstrauen in unserer durchrüttelten Welt. Dieses Buch ist so schlecht, ich konnte es gar nicht glauben. Für mich rangiert leider der Autor jetzt Haaresbreite über Markus Gabriel. Oh je. Es ist wirklich vernichtend. Und die Potemkinische Mediengruppe, die süddeutsche Zeitung Jörg Henschel, hat sich Wolfram Weimers gigantisches Medienimperium angeschaut. 293 Abonnenten. The Verge hat einen Text aufgegriffen, den es schon woanders gab, nämlich bei Benjamin Riley. Die haben ihn gebeten, nochmal ein Argument auszubauen, der selbst ist Mitglied einer, wie nennt man das, NGO, irgendwie Cognitive Resonance, die also gegen den AI-Hype ankämpft. Das kommt dir sehr entgegen und ich finde es auch wahnsinnig interessant, aber es stellen sich noch soziologische Fragen, die wir gleich mal aufgreifen. Und Sven Kalisch hat Born, Rich or Die, Trying, eine wunderbare Auftröselung über die deutsche Erbengesellschaft mit der Ankündigung, weitere thematische Texte anschließen zu lassen. Ich sehe hier die Anbahnung einer Enzyklopädie zum Thema, was uns alle interessiert. Und zwar bei Substack einfach so als Privatvergnügen. Und das ist ja auch ein Format, das ich immer besser finde so, dass jetzt immer mehr Leute immer mehr Kram machen. Und von daher hier Blogosphere 2.0 oder so.
Wunderbar. Das ist auch zugleich, wenn man in den Salon geht, die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut. Es ist ganz einfach, man geht auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de. Dort wird man dann zu Steady geführt. Es ist alles selbsterklärend. Man kann dann einfach ein Abo machen. Am besten ein Jahresabo gleich. Das ist dann auch günstiger. Es ist aber auch für diejenigen, die schon bei Patreon sind, möglich, dort den Salon zu abonnieren. Oder wer bei Apple es ganz bequem haben will, kann das auch darüber tun. Bei Steady gibt es jetzt auch noch die Möglichkeit, weil ja bald Weihnachten ist, dass man den Salon verschenkt. Man kann also für ein Jahr irgendjemanden den Salon verschenken. Und dieses Abo wird dann auch nach einem Jahr aufgelöst, wenn die Person es dann nicht für sich selbst verlängern will. Das geht natürlich dann auch. Aber man ist dann nicht ein Leben lang daran gebunden an dieses Geschenk, sondern kann für ein Jahr den...
Du musst deine Wirtschaft übernehmen, wie für die Neuanköpplige.
Eben nicht. Es ist also ganz selbsterklärend und einfach. Also wir freuen uns sehr, wenn ihr den Salon unterstützt auf diese Weise und den Podcast auf diese Weise unterstützt. Es gibt ja dann auch in diesem Winter, in diesem Dezember noch einen Live-Salon, nämlich in der nächsten Woche sind wir noch einmal in der CAS. Wir geben auch gleich noch mal im Salon die vier Termine durch, wann man uns in der CAS erleben kann.
Nächstes Jahr. Genau.
Nächstes Jahr.
Ja, so ist es. Ihr kriegt im Steady-Archiv alle Folgen. Nur jetzt gerade ziehen die Dateien auf einen neuen Server. Das heißt, ab nächster Woche sind die sehr viel schneller runterladbar. Und jetzt gerade kann es ein paar Hick-Ups geben. Aber Steady kümmert sich, haben sie mir versprochen.
Wunderbar. Also dort findet man dann übrigens auch, weil wir jetzt ein paar E-Mails bekommen haben nach Geschenktipps. Nun ja, wir haben jetzt ja so viele Bücher besprochen. In den letzten Monaten auch noch mal Einzelempfehlungen dabei gehabt. Ich habe ja fast jedes Mal was Literarisches noch dabei. Da findet man jetzt wirklich Geschenkideen noch und nöcher. Ich glaube, wir brauchen jetzt nicht noch mal extra zehn Bücher nennen, die man verschenken kann. Da ist alles dabei oder den Salon verschenken.
In der Ansicht habe ich jetzt meinen Freundeskreis erweitert um diese ganzen KI-Sachen. Es ist einfach nur der Zeit geschuldet, dass neuezwanzige.de noch nicht so eine richtig große Stöberseite ist, wo auch alle Argumente, die wir zu den hunderten Büchern, die wir besprochen haben, noch mal schön durchsuchbar und so weiter. Also wenn ihr dann nächstes Jahr Geschenke sucht und kluge Sachen verschenken wollt, dann können wir bei neuezwanziger.de Sachen anbieten. Das haben die Föhtons in Deutschland, die auch zum Jahresende immer so jeder Redakteur schreibt mal kurz drei Zeilen zu irgendwas, noch nicht gesehen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was da kommt.
Der Schatz wird gehoben.
Gut, dann bis gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.